heftig ist es ist wirklich krass krank
und keine ahnung irgendwie das hätten
auch ich sein können ehrlich das hätte
ich sein können hey was klappt jetzt
bekommen bei neuen video haben wir
wahrscheinlich schon erkannt habt mir
ist es endlich wieder gelungen zum
friseur zu wohl deshalb die bürger schon
gesehen er ist auch scheißegal
auf jeden fall gibt es heute ein neues
video das ganze mache ich heute nicht
alleine ich habe eine relativ bekanntes
gesicht dabei dass dem einen oder
anderen von euch eventuell auch schon
wie sagt man dass geläufig sei auch dass
auf jeden fall geht's heute hier mit
rookie tyler spurgeon kempter so leute
wie lucas onkologie tag und ich weiß
auch dass ich hier mache auf jeden fall
hat er allerdings nicht dazu gezwungen
bei ihm mitzumachen ich habe jetzt nicht
so dass dazu aber ich mache ihnen muss
halt sein so was aber machen und ja ja
und wir haben uns zusammengesetzt und
wirklich das kreativste das
außergewöhnlichste das heftigste format
ever überlegt das heißt format also das
ist ein video and wir haben uns auf
jeden fall was krass unterhaltsames
überlegt was ich auf noch nie gemacht
habe
außerhalb manchmal und zwar haben wir
beiden natürlich wieder kräftig
irgendwelche beichten oder heftige
stories von euch zugeschickt bekommen
und ja da haben wir uns zwei von
rausgesucht die eine ist auf meinem
channel die andere auf seinem channel
und eine davon ist riehl und die andere
ist fake ich will auch eigentlich gar
nicht eingeladen sondern direkt anfangen
auf jeden fall auf seinem schimmel ist
halt auch noch eine beichte und ja
schaut euch einfach an und von meiner
beichte die ich hier erzähle mit ihm
zusammen halt auch auf meinem tunnel
erfahrt ihr in seinem video am ende ob
die richtig ist oder nicht ihr könnt
natürlich auch schon mit raten deswegen
schreibt doch einfach mal während oder
nach der beichte hier drunter
ob ihr glaubt dies will oder ob ihr
glaubt dies fällt und ja das ganze löst
dann er auf seinem channel auf ich lös
seine beichte auf meinem channel auf das
ist dann halt so ein bisschen hin und
her finde ich ganz cool ich hoffe das
gefällt euch wir fangen direkt an ich
habe wirklich was heftiges das ist
wirklich krass krank und keine ahnung
irgendwie das hätten auch ich sein
können ehrlich das hätte ich sein können
bei mir geht es natürlich um ein mädchen
herr alex ich bin weiblich und 15 jahre
alt ich möchte dir eine geschichte
erzählen die zwar schon ein paar jahre
alt ist ist mir aber immer noch total
paket dann wollen wir doch mal
weiterlesen
da ist mir noch total peinlich also wir
fahren schon seitdem ich drei oder vier
jahre alt bin jedes jahr in den
skiurlaub
dabei kommen wir jedes jahr an demselben
gebäude nenne ich es jetzt mal vorbei
dort ist auch ein rastplatz und manchmal
halten wir dort an also früher zumindest
klingt erstmal natürlich voll der wahl
gebäude an der autobahn ist
wahrscheinlich irgendeiner raststätte
wohnt schnitzel 25 euro 70 kostet auf
jeden fall ja gebäude nenne ich es jetzt
mal dort war ja klar ich fande das
gebäude irgendwie immer total cool als
ich klein war das heißt atlantis und für
mich sah das immer so aus wie so ein
cooles schwimmbad atlantis wird sich für
mich jetzt auf wie ein schwimmbad
anhören so erstmal klar es könnte auch
was anderes sein aber ich würde erstmal
sagen schwimmbad ich habe meinen eltern
auch immer gefragt ob wir dort nicht mal
schwimmen gehen können
aber die haben immer sofort gesagt dass
wir das niemals tun werden also ich
hätte das auch verstanden ich meine wenn
man so open weg ist voll im stress im
urlaub dann geht man doch nicht auf dem
weg schwimmen als ich dann ich glaube so
acht oder neun jahre alt war sind wir
wieder in den urlaub gefahren und haben
einen rastplatz wo halt auch dieses
atlantis ist rast gemacht ok und jetzt
kommt der höhepunkt der story mit dem
ende hält erzählt von luk italien viel
spaß
let's go ich hoffe du machst es gut wenn
ich mache ich nie wieder ein video mit
dir strich an rubik's habe bei meinem
video findet ihr die auflösung zu dieser
beichte also diese taktik auf echt ist
oder ob sich der alles nur ausgedacht
hat und würde sagen ich war es weiter
mit der beichte
ich war anscheinend immer noch total
begeistert davon
und als ich meinen eltern gesagt habe
dass ich im auto sitzen bleibe bin ich
einfach ausgestiegen und in das gebäude
rein genau finden und ich merke schon du
bist ein richtig kleiner lebendig wird
ein richtiger kleiner gangster
komischerweise konnte ich das auch
betreten
das hat wohl keiner beim reingehen
gesehen oder so denke ich wahrscheinlich
wollte da hat einfach so klein war es
dass jeder würde ich darüber gesehen hat
das kind warst und man dachte du wärst
dazu oder so als ich dann drin war kann
mir das direkt sehr komisch vor aber ich
dachte was ist das ja eine art
schwimmbad wo andernach baden gehen
wie soll ich
komisch dass alle leute nackt sind gehe
ich auch einfach mal also würde ich auch
machen wer macht es nicht doch dann kam
plötzlich so ein nackter mann auf mich
zu der meinte ich soll ganz schnell raus
dann habe ich an bekommen und bin
schnell wieder raus gelaufen ja es hätte
ich auch an seiner stelle wenden ihr ein
nackter mann entgegen kommt wenn ich 19
jahre alt wäre ich würde rennen
also ich verstehe ich schon meine eltern
haben mir schon besucht weil ich halt
nicht mehr im auto saß und als sie
erfahren haben was in der zeit gemacht
habe habe ich ganz schön doll ärger
bekommen sodass ich angefangen habe zu
beiden deshalb immer noch peinlich
okay das ist wirklich verständlich das
kannst du dann eltern durch nicht böse
leben denn wenn sie sich keine sorgen
gemacht hätten wäre das schon echt
komisch unserer neuen jahre altes kind
ist weggelaufen zeug wird sorgen machen
nein das passt schon so das war's würde
weiters schreibt mir die kommentare
hashtags stimmt aber total hoffentlich
lässt alex alex stark dass nicht raus
und uns rausschmeißt dann auf jeden fall
dabei sein durfte hat mir gefreut bist
du erst mal fertig ging ja schnell
irgendwie ja was glaubt ihr war dieses
areal oder weil sie fällt schreibt jetzt
und in die comments reihen ich bin
heftig gespannt und irgendwie dann sehen
wir mal was dabei rumkommt okay dann
kommen wir jetzt zu der auflösung von
loki story also auf seinem channel
falls ihr die noch nicht gesehen habt
dann schaut euch jetzt erst an bevor er
wirklich so jetzt erfahren ob das spiel
war oder fake war
ich kann euch nämlich sagen
wir haben zwar eine beichte von
irgendwem mädchen bekommen was irgendwie
schwanger war allerdings haben wir das
ein bisschen ausgeschmückt das heißt
diese beichte auf seinem channel war so
wie sie erzählt war ziemlich überspitzt
dargestellt und somit fake das war halt
nicht so schlimm ich hoffe ihr hattet
dennoch spaß das video anzuschauen und
meinen wieder anzuschauen schaut euch
auf jeden fall sein video an falls es
noch nicht gemacht habe das war ja ganz
oben in der video beschreibung verlinkt
abonniert ihn auch wenn ihr wollt wenn
nicht dann halt nicht ist sollte auf
jeden fall würde ich sagen wir sehen uns
am dienstag wieder
dort kommt ein neues cooles video um 18
online muss gerade luftholen ja dann
sehen wir uns dienstag wie schon gesagt
das ist ja mal sein checkers ab und
vertrat peace love you here sage ich
hier schon wieder